Hace ya unos años que la gran mayoría de
analistas internacionales sentenciaron que
el dominio absoluto del mundo por parte de
Estados Unidos había llegado a su fin.
Aquel escenario que resultó de la caída
del muro de Berlín y del fin de la Unión
Soviética, y que alimentó a un mundo unipolar
presidido por el tío Sam, se desvaneció
para muchos.
¿Por qué?
Por una razón muy simple, por el auge de
un país que empezó a plantarle cara a Estados
Unidos.
Y, no, evidentemente, no estamos hablando
de una Rusia renovada tras la caída de la
URSS, sino del gigante asiático, os hablamos,
por supuesto, de China.
Y no es para menos, al fin y al cabo, hablamos
de un país que se ha convertido en la mayor
potencia industrial y la segunda mayor economía
de todo el planeta.
China está mucho más cerca del oro estadounidense
que del bronce japonés.
Pero no se trata solo de una cuestión económica.
China también es, y lo es cada vez más,
una importante potencia militar.
De hecho, exceptuando el tema nuclear, China
podría tener ya las segundas fuerzas armadas
con más capacidad de todo el mundo.
Y claro, con semejante poder industrial, económico
y militar…
El fin del mundo unipolar no es que parezca
cantado, es que es ya un hecho.
Claro, mantener el ritmo de Estados Unidos
no resulta nada fácil.
Y aunque China ha hecho unos esfuerzos impresionantes,
muchos analistas ya están señalando la fatiga
del gigante asiático.
Especialmente porque unas fuerzas armadas
modernas y grandes necesitan sobre todo uno
cosa: dinero.
Y por eso, hoy aquí, en VisualPolitik, nos
hacemos unas cuantas preguntas:
¿En qué situación se encuentra China?
¿Es posible que la desaceleración o incluso
la crisis frene su apuesta militar?
¿Cómo se está fortaleciendo?
¿Sabías que China cuenta ya con la mayor
fuerza naval de todo el mundo?
¿Qué puede suponer esto?
Pues bien, respondamos a todas estas preguntas.
Vamos con ello.
T1 (XI JINPING, ¿EL ANTI-GURÚ ECONÓMICO?)
Durante décadas, China ha desafiado todo
evidencia y previsión hasta convertirse en
la mayor autocracia y en un régimen autoritario
con bastante éxito.
Si en su día se pensó que el desarrollo
traería conOIsigo una mayor apertura y mayores
niveles de libertad, los hechos han demostrado
que esa tesis no era correcta.
Desde los años 70, con las reformas económicas
y políticas aperturistas de Deng Xiaoping,
y gracias a sus abundantes recursos demográficos,
energéticos e hídricos, China consiguió
sacar a 800 millones de personas de la pobreza
y crecer un 10% anual hasta el final del mandato
de Hu Jintao en 2012.
Sin embargo, desde la llegada de Xi Jinping
al poder y, sobre todo, en los últimos años,
China ha empezado a tomar otro camino:
(Desde la llegada de Xi Jinping a la presidencia,
algunas de las medidas que auparon a la República
Popular de China al podio mundial han sufrido
un importante revés: Xi Jinping ha involucionado
hacIa formas mucho más autoritarias e intervencionistas.
Ha fortalecido el aparato de vigilancia del
Estado, ha dado prioridad a las empresas públicas,
lo que ha incluido regar de grandes cantidades
de capital a muchas de las empresas estatales
zombis.
Además, hay que tener en cuenta que la China
de Xi ya no cuenta con las ventajas con las
que contaron sus predecesores.
Los costes salariales han crecido, el mercado
inmobiliario está saturado, el país cada
vez está importando más energía y la población
china está envejeciendo y contrayéndose.
Para 2050, las estimaciones apuntan a que
700 millones de trabajadores deberán mantener
a 500 millones de pensionistas, 300 millones
más que en la actualidad.)
Por eso, no es de extrañar que China ya no
esté presentando un crecimiento como el que
tenía antes de la llegada de Xi Jinping.
De hecho, desde la crisis del 2008 el crecimiento
económico de China prácticamente no ha dejado
de caer.
Xi no ha logrado frenar la desaceleración
de la economía China.
Y eso a pesar de que ha utilizado enormes
paquetes de gasto público para intentar lograrlo.
Y no se trata solo de eso.
Tal y como ya os hemos contado un montón
de veces en nuestro boletín de Patreon, Las
Claves de la Semana, la economía china se
está enfrentando a muchísimos problemas.
Por cierto, si os gusta lo que hacemos, queréis
ayudarnos a crecer y a seguir mejorando, podéis
uniros a la comunidad de VisualPolitik de
Patreon en patreon.com/visualpolitik.
Además, por muy poco podréis recibir un
montón de contenido extra y también regalos
exclusivos.
Os dejo toda la info en la descripción.
Pero dicho esto, si hablamos de problemas
en China tenemos que tener en cuenta también
este dato.
Fijaos.
N1 (La deuda de China en relación con el
PIB aumenta hasta un récord del 279,7% por
el auge del crédito.
Bloomberg)
A esto se le une el cierre de 4.4 millones
de negocios que se vieron obligados a cerrar
debido a la dura política de “Covid 0”.
Y, aunque es verdad que el desempleo ha caído
del 5.3% al 5.2%, la realidad es que el desempleo
juvenil se situó por encima del 21% en junio
de este año.
Y lo cierto, es que, en general, las previsiones
económicas sobre China se están revisando
a la baja en comparación con periodos anteriores
de su historia.
Por ejemplo, Goldman Sachs, que previó que
la economía china superaría en 2026 a la
americana y que para 2050 su PIB sería el
doble que el del tío Sam, tuvo que revisar
el año pasado sus previsiones.
Entonces predijo que China superaría a Estados
Unidos en 2035 y que, como mucho, superaría
solo en un 15% al PIB estadounidense.
Quizás hoy todavía sean menos optimistas.
De hecho, cada vez son más los analistas
que ponen en cuestión que China logre siquiera
alcanzar a Estados Unidos.
Y eso hablando de PIB en términos absolutos
y sin tener nada más en cuenta.
Y, ojo, porque esto no es una declaración
anti-China ni nada por el estilo.
Todo lo contrario.
En VisualPolitik hemos celebrado y contado
los grandes avances cosechados por este país.
Un país que, en líneas generales, ha tenido
una contribución muy positiva para el mundo
en los últimos 40 años.
Sin embargo, desde hace unos años también
os venimos contando que las cosas tanto desde
el punto de vista económico como político
se están deteriorando, o al menos están
dejando de ir también.
Os hablamos de ello hace un par de años,
y eso es lo que está ocurriendo.
Porque más allá de la propaganda los datos
están sobre la mesa.
Claro que, un momento, porque quizás muchos
consideréis que el hecho de que el gigante
asiático quizás no supere económicamente
a Estados Unidos es una excelente noticia.
Sin embargo, ¿sabéis qué?
Muchos de los analistas que hacen este pronóstico
también defienden que esto puede suponer
un grave peligro.
Pero…
¿Cómo es eso posible?
¿No se supone que lo más peligroso sería
lo contrario?
Pues…
Atentos.
T2 (LA GRAN MARINA CHINA)
Estoy seguro de que muchos habéis escuchado
estos últimos años que el auge de China
podrá poner en serios aprietos a Estados
Unidos.
Incluso, ha habido algunos reputados analistas,
como Graham Allison de la Universidad de Harvard,
que han apuntado a que el auge de China y
la consecuente caída de Estados Unidos llevaría
a una guerra inevitable.
Sin embargo, viendo la situación actual de
China y sus cada vez más pobres proyecciones
de crecimiento, muchos analistas ya están
empezando a dejar de lado la teoría de Allison.
Hoy, estos analistas han empezado a abrazar
otra teoría: China está llegando a su punto
álgido, que sigue estando por debajo de Estados
Unidos, y una vez que llegue a ese punto,
empezará su declive.
Es este escenario, según ellos, el verdaderamente
preocupante para Estados Unidos y para todo
el mundo.
¿Por qué?
Por una simple razón: porque, al igual que
no hay animal más peligroso que el que está
herido, no hay país más peligroso que el
que está en declive.
Cuando para intentar evitar su caída no pocas
veces recurren a la violencia
Y, ¿sabéis que ha estado haciendo China
todos estos años?
Pues…
Fijaos.
Efectivamente, ha estado incrementando su
presupuesto en defensa: un 9% anual desde
que se puso en marcha a modernización del
Ejército anunciada en los 90.
De esta forma, China ha llegado a tener un
presupuesto militar de $224.000 millones para
el 2023, el segundo más grande de todo el
mundo.
Con todo ese dinero, China ha estado modernizando
progresivamente sus capacidades e instalaciones
militares.
Por ejemplo, hoy cuenta ya con 1.700 aviones
de combate, entre los que encontramos aviones
J-11 o Su-30, comparables con los F-16 o F-18
de Estados Unidos.
De hecho, China cuenta ya con la mayor fuerza
aérea de toda Asia.
Sin embargo, ¿adivináis en qué rama del
Ejército ha hecho la mayor inversión?
3, 2,1…
Pues sí, lo habéis adivinado, en la marina.
(La modernización naval de China comenzó
en los años 90 y ha conseguido que la marina
china se convierta en la más grande del mundo,
al menos en número, con 351 navíos en 2022,
por encima incluso de la estadounidense, que
contó con 294 embarcaciones ese mismo año.
Además, no solo cuenta con más naves, sino
que las capacidades de estas también han
mejorado sustancialmente desde los 90.
Entre otras, gracias a la inclusión de misiles
balísticos y de crucero antibuque, entre
otros muchos equipos.
Y no solo eso, China también cuenta con una
gran flota de submarinos, destructores y cruceros.
Es más, incluso ha conseguido establecerse
como la segunda potencia con más portaaviones:
en 2012 y en 2019 presentó sus dos primeros,
y en 2022 presentó su tercer portaaviones,
el Fujian.
Un buque que ya cuenta con capacidades como
el uso de catapultas o un diseño electromagnético
usado para el lanzamiento de jets.
)
Sin embargo, ¿creéis que con esta gran flota
China podría derrotar a la marina estadounidense?
Pues, por el momento, no parece que sea el
caso.
Veréis, es cierto que China tiene una mayor
cantidad de navíos militares.
De hecho, se espera que para 2030 su marina
sea incluso un 50% más grande q ue la de
Estados Unidos.
Pero la realidad, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
es que, aunque el tío Sam cuente con menos
navíos, los suyos son más grandes, completos
y capaces.
Por ejemplo, en comparación con los portaaviones
chinos, los estadounidenses son mucho más
grandes, están propulsados por energía nuclear,
lo que les da mayor autonomía, y pueden embarcar
y operar un mayor número de aviones, incluso
más de 60.
Además, tened en cuenta que Estados Unidos
cuenta con más embarcaciones cruciales a
nivel militar como portaaviones, cruceros
o destructores, lo que les daría una clara
ventaja en un escenario de guerra.
No obstante, independientemente de si China
se está preparando para llegar a su pico
y empezar a caer o no, lo que está claro
es que China se ha convertido en una potencia
militar, y sobre todo naval, formidable.
De eso no cabe duda.
Pero ¿por qué tanta inversión en la marina?
Pues, ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3 (UNA PARTIDA DE RISK)
Muchos han intentado descubrir cuál sería
la estrategia de China para poder convertirse
en una superpotencia capaz de hacerle frente
a Estados Unidos, y la mayoría han concluido
que todo pasa por una región: el dominio
del Mar de la China Meridional.
Si China se hiciera con el control total de
esta región, todo apunta a que ya podríamos
estar hablando de una superpotencia al nivel
del tío Sam.
Y es que, veréis, en este mar hay unas reservas
probadas de 11.000 millones de barriles de
petróleo, y aún más de gas natural.
Pero lo verdaderamente importante de este
mar es la enorme ventaja geoestratégica que
le proporcionaría al contendiente que lograra
hacerse con él por completo.
Y, en este caso, el mayor contendiente es
China.
(El fortalecimiento naval de China se explica
por su ambición de convertirse en una potencia
mundial con capacidad para moldear el orden
internacional, pero también para asegurar
y proteger sus rutas comerciales marítimas,
ya que el 80% de las operaciones comerciales
chinas se llevan a cabo por esta vía.
Por eso, China no ha dudado en pasar por encima
del Derecho Internacional y establecer la
famosa “línea de los 9 puntos” para intentar
reducir el riesgo de que se produzca un corte
de suministro de bienes estratégicos, como,
por ejemplo, el petróleo.
Como recordaréis, la “línea de los 9 puntos”
es el territorio que China reclama como soberano,
pese a que interfiere con las zonas económicas
exclusivas de vecinos como Filipinas, Vietnam,
Malasia o Brunéi.
Pues bien, dentro de esta línea reclamada
por China se encuentran islas que sus vecinos
también reclaman, como las de los archipiélagos
de las islas Spratly o Paracel, islas que
China ha tomado por la fuerza y que ha militarizado
y expandido artificialmente.)
Sin embargo, la razón principal, o al menos
la más comentada en general, no es esta,
sino la intención de China de invadir próximamente
la isla de Formosa, es decir, Taiwán.
N2 (China prevé la "unificación armada"
con Taiwán para 2027: académico clave.
Asia Nikkei)
(El ministro de Asuntos Exteriores de Taiwán
advierte de un conflicto con China en 2027.
The Guardian)
Este es, seguramente, el mayor punto de tensión
entre Estados Unidos y China.
Entre otras cosas y chips aparte, porque Taiwán
sirve como una barrera que evita que China
tenga vía libre para expandirse hacia el
Indo-Pacífico.
Precisamente por eso, actualmente, China está
invirtiendo tantos recursos en su marina.
Pensadlo bien, si China se lanzara a tomar
todo el Mar de la China Meridional, incluida
Taiwán, Estados Unidos tendría menos capacidad
de actuación teniendo en cuenta que sus aviones
de combate se encuentran a más de 1.000 km,
en Okinawa y en Guam.
Además, China podría desplegar aviones de
combate en las islas Spratly y Parecel fácilmente
desde sus 4 bases aéreas localizadas en el
mar.
Y, no solo eso, el gigante asiático ha establecido
un fuerte sistema de radares en las islas
y, además, cuenta con un mayor número de
misiles en la región.
No obstante, ¿creéis de verdad que sería
tan fácil derrotar a Estados Unidos?
Como os podéis imaginar, esto es algo más
bien improbable.
No solo porque Estados Unidos tenga mucha
más experiencia reciente en guerras y unos
navíos más avanzados, sino también porque,
como apuntan muchos analistas chinos, para
poder tener éxito en un conflicto de tal
naturaleza, China debería resolver primero
algunos inconvenientes:
Hablamos de detalles como el suministro de
armas a Taiwán desde Estados Unidos, la inexistencia
de un plan frente a las sanciones que seguro,
seguro, le serían impuestas, la incapacidad
actual de tomar de manera extremadamente rápida
Taiwán, y un largo etcétera.
Ya lo veis, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
los analistas ya vaticinan la llegada del
tope de crecimiento de China.
No obstante, esto lejos de acabar con las
aspiraciones chinas de dominar por completo
el Mar de la China Meridional y plantarle
cara a cara con Estados Unidos como una superpotencia,
las puede estar reforzando.
Xi ya ha conseguido que China tenga la mayor
flota naval militar internacional, ahora solo
queda preguntarse: ¿cuándo mostrará toda
su capacidad naval al mundo?
¿De verdad que China no alcanzará a Estados
Unidos como primera potencia mundial?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.